and it was very very effective
because ultimately what happened is
david muscavich walked into the irs
headquarters
in washington dc and said i want to meet
the commissioner i want to see the
commissioner
and this was right after you guys that
filed thousands of lawsuits people they
were just getting
all these freedom magazines we were
taking out full-page ads in usa today
about the irs full page ads in the new
york times
like it was so just like in other ways
of putting it
just unloading all kinds of arti
artillery on them to where they were
just like
beat up correct and
miscavitch um and marty rathbun
walked into the irs headquarters and
said they walked up the reception desk
and said
i we want to see the commissioner do you
have an appointment
no just tell david miscavige is here
from the church of scientology
and they didn't meet with him that day
but three days later they did
and fred goldberg who was the irs
commissioner at the time
said look can you guys
can you turn off the faucet
can you can we just be done and
miscavitch said of course we can
just give us exemption fred goldberg
then formed a special committee
inside the irs to review scientology tax
exempt status
and it was headed by the deputy
commissioner of the irs for exempt
organizations at the time a guy called
john burke
okay and john burke was a really nice
guy and but he was retiring
he had absolutely nothing to lose it was
he was at the end of his career
yeah and so he and a bunch of
other irs officials formed this
committee and
they asked hundreds of questions
and wanted millions of documents and
i literally commuted between
la and dc with miscavitch and marty
rathbun
and a few other people for almost two
years
having meetings with the irs routinely
and providing them with documents and
answers to their questions
and in the end they basically said okay
we give
what they were really looking for was
enough justification to be
able to grant the exemption
because they had been mandated by the
irs commissioner originally
we need to turn we need to shut this
[ __ ] down
yeah review this so
really their mandate was to review it to
figure out how they could do it
because they had a problem a big problem
there was a united states supreme court
case
called hernandez v commissioner where
one of those
people that i told you who had had their
deductions denied
took the case all the way to the u.s
supreme court jesus
and two years before this whole thing
with the irs
the u.s supreme court said that
donations or payments to scientology
were not tax deductible because
they are a quid pro quo transaction now
quid pro quo
has become a big everybody knows what it
is now
back back then it was uh it was like
tax people knew about it and that was
all and
there had all there also the case of the
church of spiritual technology had been
lost and appealed to the federal appeals
court and have been
lost in the federal appeals court so
there were these
decisions that they had to somehow
circumvent
and honestly to this day
i've talked to various tax professors
and professionals
and they don't really understand how the
irs got away with this
and at the time when the when the
settlement of granting scientology
exemption was
announced and it was secret for quite a
while
yeah and the the the actual document
laying out the settlement was secret
the wall street journal and the new york
times were like up in arms about
this is outrageous and how this happened
and blah blah blah
and scientology just kind of
we just kind of went you know cell
grapes tough
you know whatever and that became
in the eyes of scientologists
miscavitch's claim to fame
in october of 1993 when the irs granted
this
exemption he held a huge
event in the at the
the um la sports arena
and they were about staple center no it
was
it's before it's where the clippers used
to play oh okay yeah yeah yeah
i know you're talking about and uh there
were about 10 000 people from all over
scientologists from all over the world
that were gathered for this event
and he announced this victory and
it was you know fireworks and
and he was on this huge stage that looks
like a nuremberg
rally with sconces and flames and
the announcement was ultimately after a
long-winded explanation about how rotten
the irs is and they did this and they
did that and we did this
we did that and we blah blah blah
the war is over that was what the final
announcement was
the war is over we won
and this cemented
in the mind of scientologists including
me
that miscavitch had pulled off and
accomplished something that l ron
hubbard hadn't been able to
and that he had applied the exact
policies of hubbard on fair game
and how you destroy enemies and how you
go after people
always attack never defend
etc etc and it worked
and the the um
credibility that this gave miscavitch
lasts to this day miscavige can do no
wrong in the eyes of scientologists
partly because of that
and when there is massive hits on
scientology pr wise like
when going clear and on hbo or when the
aftermath was showing
he would routinely order that all
scientologists were to re-watch
that event it's in every scientology
church and mission around the world and
people are ordered to come in and
re-watch the
it's called now the turning point event
and it is two hours of david miscavige
patting himself on the back
and then announcing that he's done what
nobody else could do and got an
exemption from the irs
now what happens with documentaries like
hbo's going clear
do they in scientology do they confront
that
like do they like say hey watch this
documentary here's where it's
wrong no no no it is forbidden
to watch uh
what's called n theta n theta
is a scientology term which means
uh interpolated theta with theta like
you said
is the the term for the spirit or
spiritual things
and interpolation is upset and
n theta is bad news that's a it's sort
of
short it's the scientology word for what
we would say
bad news and so scientologists are not
allowed to
watch uh going clear or the aftermath
or read the saint pete times when the
truth rundown series came out in the
saint pete times in 2009
yeah it's a three-part three-part series
yeah yeah
yeah scientology went around and bought
all the newspapers emptied
all the newsstands in clearwater so that
no scientologist would be able to get
that
paper and that has happened routinely
and it is thought in scientology that
if you are exposed to that sort of
uh negative information that
it will cause you to be what's called in
scientology a potential trouble source
you will become sick you will
have start having accidents bad things
will start happening to you
and you will have to undergo a course of
action uh
that will fix you up
in fact i wrote leah and i wrote an
article about this on my blog
this morning called scientology deaths
and suicides
where we go through how scientology
views sickness but this came about
because of kelly preston's
tragic death from breast cancer and lisa
marie
presley's son suicide and people keep
asking us how does this come
you know what does scientology have to
do with this and
we try to lay out and a big part of this
is this concept
that you only become
ill and you only and start having
accidents and become accident prone or
depressed or whatever when you are
connected to
a source of what's called suppression
in scientology or anybody who questions
anything
correct and this can be a person
or it can be a book
larry writes going clear book
that could be the source of why you
now suddenly became ill that you
read that book and it it
is a connection to a source of
suppression
and i mean it's a pr the title of that
book the prison of beliefs
it really encapsulates everything that
you're saying it's out of prison because
you can't question
anything no you cannot close-mindedness
absolutely your questioning in
scientology
is anathema to scientology
right there's no such thing the word of
el ron hubbard
is the word of god it is not to be
questioned it is not to be interpreted
it is not to be
uh taken in and re-fed out it is just to
be
read exactly and applied exactly as it
is read
and scientology is a very very literal
organization or literal study
it is read what he says if he says this
he means that and that's it and
it's um
it's really bad form
in scientology to question anything or
anybody and most particularly to
question l ron hubbard
although nowadays it's pretty close to
questioning our ron hubbard to question
david miscavige yeah
like he what he says
is the law and that's it
where's david miscavige today does he
live around here or does he live in one
of the one of the big buildings
the all i mean there's huge amounts of
real estate that's owned by
scientology but when when he travels
around but when he's in clearwater he
he lives at the hacienda gardens
that apartment complex that is out there
on
keane just north of drew
and
okay and he comes into the big
super power building the big building
across from the fort harrison and
the bridge that goes over the yes
exactly and he has a private
entrance that goes in the the
garage door goes up and it drives into
the basement
and he gets out in the basement and he
goes up to his
office that's in the one of the corner
turrets of that building
yeah and that's where he works
that's so that's so creepy seems like
this mysterious character now like you
never
see anything about him in public you
never see any sort of interview with him
by anybody
he's just in the in the shadows well he
doesn't want to be served with a
subpoena
he is terrified of being served with a
subpoena really
[Music]
yes
i